welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled the varied
application of dried blood spot dbs
sample collection during the coven 19
pandemic
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
jackie mandel
lead technical product specialist
saitiba
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me in welcoming dr jackie
mandel i will now turn the presentation
over to him
thank you for nice introduction
title of my presentation
is the varied application of dried blood
spot during copied 19 pandemic our
mission is to advance and accelerate
therapeutics
my presentation will cover how sample
collection device advance and accelerate
faster diagnosis the first step of
therapeutics
here is my agenda for this talk i'll
talk about what is sample collection
card with the task of historical
aspect of sample sample collection and
diagnosis
applications of 903 card where i will
discuss how this sample collection card
reduce risk monitor surveillance in
cost-effective manner i'll bring few
examples and standard protocols of
scitiva extractor nucleic acid micro
extraction from sample collection card
finally i will discuss how your
considerations
i'll discuss your considerations where
to apply this technology
let's start with
sample collection card
there are many names of sample
collection cards
whatman 903 card hotman sample
collection card dry blood spot card or
dbs card are alternatively used that
speak to the same purpose
occasionally it is referred to as
guthrie card the 903 cards rose to
prominence in 1962
after dr
robert guthrie first published
procedures for screening of newborn
babies for phenylketonuria
phenylketonuria
a disease still affects one in 12 000
people where penelope dehydrogenase that
converts phenylalanine to tyrosine is
defective as a result phenylalanine
accumulates on the surface of blood
brain barrier and impair
other nutrient transport to the brain
impairing brain's ability to protect
synthesis since then
good record
samples from two to nine day old babies
have been collected rootingly not only
for phenylketonuria but also for
congenital
hypothyroidism and sickle cell disorders
the detection
of markers of other diseases such as
human chorionic gonadotropin in down
syndrome glycated hemoglobin in insulin
dependent diabetes and the estimation of
drug levels
abuse of drugs
have also been investigated the
limitations
of sensitivity and specificity when
screening such small
volume of blood such as 5 to 10
microliter restricted the use of dried
blood spot for many years however recent
advances such as the production of
monoclonal antibodies
expression of synthetic proteins and the
introduction of the polymerase chain
reaction or pcr have overcome many of
these problems
allowing the potential of a bus bank of
store dbs
to be useful by biochemist geneticist
and microbiologist
now the dbs system is the standard for
testing antibodies or proteins vital rna
or dna bacterial rna or dna
or human animal rna or dna the world
health organ organization recommended
procedure for viral load results
obtained from plasma and dbs have proven
to be comparable
recently fda approved the vibrant
antibody chemiluminescence essay for
differentiating cells coronavitas to igm
and ig
uh g antibodies
one what man 903 card
what was the guthrie card at that time
good record was basically s and s or
slicker and swirl 903 paper
and hence it took the name 903 card
dbs card are made from 100 percent
cotton linter with no additives what man
carefully ensures homogeneous
composition uniform thickness and
absorbency
which ensure consistent sample recovery
and test performance
of hortman 903 cards
903 card is a stable and cost effective
method to obtain blood samples on five
spot protein saver cards as shown on the
left two pictures
sport perforated protein silver cars in
the top middle protein silver snap paper
card in the right moreover we offer any
custom size cards for
diverse volume of blood dry blood spot
card can be provided with scannable
barcodes maybe numbering system or with
color code
the blood spot should then be
allowed to air dry
and ideally stored in low gas permeable
bags that contain desiccant to reduce
humidity
samples can be tested immediately stored
at ambient temperature even under
tropical conditions are frozen at -20
degree celsius where the level of igg
antibodies may remain stable for several
years
some accessories necessary for the dried
blood spot
is drying
for drying and packaging drying the egg
is convenient tools hotmail drying rack
for 903 protein supercard is easily
assembled
can be affixed to a wall or countertop
with
optional who can hook and loop uh
stickers
file pack and desiccants for easy
shipping for remote analysis
so
now diverse application of
dbs
so intended uses for
dbs samples dbs obtained from children
and adults have been used for the
diagnosis of infections
and for sentinel surveys in many parts
of the world
surveillance surveillance detect acute
or past exposure or infection for
surveillance both molecular and antibody
testing
can be used surveillance was world
health organizations mandate for hiv
infection service now
in this pandemic world health
organization is trying to understand
from kovite 19 pandemic surveillance
how much of the population has been
infected with this cells coronavirus 2
causing
kobit 19. how is this changing over time
are there different characteristics or
risk factors
that are associated with certain
coronavirus to infection such as is
location or underlying health conditions
how many residents
experience mild or symptomatic covid19
illness
how long can antibody be found after
coppet19 infection
also case management of suspects
detect active infection for case
management of suspects molecular or
antigen testing can be used
contracted tracing detect asymptomatic
or symptomatic acute infection for
contract tracing molecular and antigen
testing can be used
monitoring response or recovery
for monitoring response or recovery both
molecular and antibody testing can be
used prognosis uh for
prognosis may be cytokine response
sometimes gives the clear answer
but for environmental monitoring only
molecular detection is needed
there is world health organization
mandate about sample types
that allows plasma serum whole blood
fresh or frozen or dbs sample in any
sample types the sensitivity and
specificity must meet regulatory
guidelines
so other applications of dbs can be
has been proven to be useful for
hepatitis c hepatitis b drug resistance
viral load monitoring
human immunodeficiency sexual
transmitted disease bovine anti-brussel
abortions detection malaria tuberculosis
for example
about surveillance of hiv
actually
in the beginning of this surveillance
it initiated a huge doubt
over the sensitivity and specificity of
dbs-based tests
compared to plasma serum dbs contains
host cells protein and nucleic acid
whereas plasma or serum has a kind of
pure nucleic acid from infectious
organisms so the dbs was not out of
doubt about its sensitivity and
specificity
the other point was the volume of sample
from dbs it's limited to five to ten
microliters so the chance of false
negative result was another doubt but
dbs is compared to its serological essay
by parallel testing of
dbs and sarah which
showed 99 to 100 percent concordance
furthermore laboratory said the centers
for disease control atlanta extended the
screening quality assurance program to
include test panels of anti-hiv positive
and negative dbs which were distributed
throughout the usa and overseas
subsequently a similar quality control
program was made available by the
central public health laboratory in
london
since the
inception of anonymous screening
several millions dbs have been tested
enabling accurate data to be obtained
about the prevalence of hiv one
similar surveillance has been done for
human t cell leukemia
or lymphoma virus it's called stlb
sdlb one has been recognized as the
causal agent of adult t cell leukemia
transmission may occur by several means
including breast feeding and through
contaminated blood in order to assess
the extent of hdlb or human t-cell
leukemia lymphoma virus
in women of childbearing is a modified
gelatin particle assay costing very
little per test was used to screen over
thousands dbas obtained from units
another example of surveillance was done
for toxoplasma gandhi toxoplasma gandhi
is recognized to be a major cause of
congenital infection which may result in
mental retardation however the
prevalence of infection varies
widely in european countries a modified
latex text
test consisting very little per test has
been used
for extensive service to determine the
maternal prevalence of antibodies
i should talk about detection of nucleic
acid in dbs
the potential for the use of dbs for the
detection of nucleic acid was first
realized in 1987
when dna was released from the filter
paper by microextraction the molecular
analysis of dna obtained from neonates
has enabled detection of genetic
mutations responsible for cystic
fibrosis oncogenesis
markers of type 1 diabetes and
thalassemia
the stability of dna has made it
possible to apply pcr to detect
provider hiv dna sequences several
months after sample collection
even when dbs had been held at room
temperature
recent studies have shown that hiv dna
and rna can be recovered after five
years without refrigeration
an
unexpected benefit of storage is that
inhibitors of pcr such as protein
hemoglobin and iron seem to become
increasingly resistant to illusion into
the sample
whereas nucleic acid seems to aid
stability and does not impair its
solution
so vital load monitoring for hiv this is
an practical example where it is being
used
so ministry of health global health
organization a part of cdc
[Music]
and national institute of health bright
blood spot samples have been used for
the detection of
severe acute respiratory syndrome
carnovirus to spike antibodies
dbs sampling offers an alternative for
population-wide serologic testing in the
corner virus pandemic for vital load
monitoring key products used are
903 cards or dbs cards accessories such
as drying racks
so another example
of use of
903 card
in national scientific institute medical
research in in oils
where scientists have developed a
convenient low-cost antibody test for
covid19 based on dried blood spot
sampling technique the novel antibody
test uses a single drop of blood and
blot it on a specialized 903 cards the
cards
can then be shipped to laboratories for
testing
once there is the laboratory a disk is
punched out from the card and the
antibodies are released
using a specialized liquid called
extraction buffer they have optimized
the enzyme leak
enzyme-linked immunosorbent assay or
elisa antibody test to be used with the
dbs method and translating the test onto
an automated platform
will allow hundreds of samples to be
tested at once
now i'll give you some examples of
collection protocol
sample collection by a skin puncture
blood can be collected from skin
puncture or venipuncture venous blood is
the specimen of choice for more rooting
left test or reference ranges but skin
punctured blood is preferred for remote
sample collection
or when sample amount of blood
when small amount of blood is adequate
for the test
and the specimen of choice for
pediatrics
elderly severely burned patients with
thrombotic tendencies
extremely obese apprehensive patients
and home-based test small amount of
blood is easier to manage
in remote areas such as home or clinics
the collection on dbs is pretty simple
right after finger prick apply pressure
allow a large drop of free flowing blood
to collect quickly and gently toss card
with blood
let blood soak through repeat until at
least all circles are filled
be sure
fill out the name
and date or other special requirements
on the cards
once the card is dried they are
ready to ship
and now what are the advantages of dbs
number one advantages is reduction of
risk
the collection of capillary blood or
filter paper is simple to perform
requires minimal training and doesn't
involve the risk associated with use and
disposal of needles and syringes
the dbs represents a low infectious
hazard as some viruses such as hiv 1 and
2
human t-cell leukemia
1 and 2 and hepatitis c virus that are
known to be present in serum or plasma
but they lose infectivity
during
due to disruption of their envelope on
drying process
however virus in high titer may remain
viable on a surface for several days and
hepatitis b virus may remain infectious
for at least seven days
risks associated with shipping are
minimized as dbs cannot leak or be
broken in transit and there is no
requirement for caries on dry ice
handling of potentially infected
material is also reduced as there is no
need to centrifuge and separate syrup
from blood clots
there is another
economic advantage collection and
processing of dbs is considerably
cheaper at least three to five times
cheaper
than samples collected by venu puncture
tbs can be readily shipped in silt
envelopes to reference centers where
whereas sera need to be
packed in brake proof containers
transport of frozen setup may require
the use of dry ice or liquid nitrogen
requiring further specialized handling
and adding considerable weight to the
item
the majority of the diagnostic technique
for example
particular agglutination test and enzyme
immunizes which have been used to screen
for antibodies in dbs are simple and
generally require little capital
expenditure the use of the agglutination
test is particularly cost effective as
they can be performed in the absence of
an electricity supply this is ideally
suited to countries with limited health
deposits
and surveillance for large-scale
epidermal is epidemic
epidemiological uh service can be
performed rapidly enabling strategic
decisions to be made about targeting
at-risk population this may be
particularly valuable for monitoring
heart immunity and the extent of vaccine
coverage at a time of
eradication
sativa genomics and molecular solutions
optimize dbs card sample collection and
dilution for molecular diagnostic of
sars coronavirus 2
the process is pretty simple using only
application of 20 microliter of blood on
903 cards dry for about 3 hours in room
10
remove 12 millimeter punch from 903 card
homogenize and extract sample using the
sera extractor virus pathogen kit
so what is extract a virus pathogen kit
this kit has been developed in response
to global kobit 19 pandemic
and aimed to address current challenges
faced with supplying kids for testing
and scientific research the format of
the kid
and a rapid protocol provide an
excellent high throughput solution that
should aid in global efforts of
scientific and medical community to
detect and study the virus
so extract a virus kit offers the
advantages of solid phase extraction
using magnetic beads
nucleic acid samples are allowed to bind
on magnetic bead surface
this is called solid face surface
washing out the unbound samples and
eluting pure nucleic acids ready to run
the test
the protocol can be adapted for both
manual and automated high throughput
processing deputy extraction procedure
can be done in less than 30 minutes
using diverse sample matrices such as
blood and universal transport transport
media at low concentration
still extractor virus kit is compatible
with molecular biology techniques
including quantitative polymerase chain
reaction droplet digital pcr
and next generation sequencing in
addition a recent study found that on
cardboard no bible search corner virus 2
was measured after 24 hours
so this is the result uh for the
detection of sars coronavirus 2 by syria
extract a virus pathogen kit from 903
card in this graph sars coronavirus 2 is
diluted in coupon universal
transport medium
with human cells rna extraction done
from 903 card within 24 hours which we
can call t0
in the lift 3 extraction
of the graph
t
rna extraction from 903 card within 14
days we can call it t14
shown last two extraction of the of the
graph
so t0 and t14
so the first three graph
and the first three
bars
and last two bars
were compared with liquid samples in the
middle
to extraction
pcr amplification was done using
non-nuclear protein primer sets and rns
negative control
as per cdc guidelines only samples for
which the anon
marker crossed the threshold at city
values are considered positive
so no implic amplification in the anon
kovite 19 specific primer set were
observed in unspiked controls and spiked
negative controls when not shown in this
graph
in this slide whole human blood stored
at room temperature on what men 903
cards for 24 hours
which is called t0 and 14 days
as a t14 ct values obtained for the n on
kovid 19 specific primer set with 50
copies per microliter or thousand copies
per extraction
of the heat inactivated viral rna in the
input sample and human specific rnsp
primer set
are presented
error bars represent standard deviation
note that kobit 19 specific
amplification was not detected in any of
the unspiked control samples uh
city undetermined data not showed
so this extractor bias kit provides
efficient total nucleic acid recovery
from different samples type and in
different concentrations with high
sensitivity in downstream detection
so here are some uh important
considerations
before using whatman 903 card
all hortman 903 card protein silver
cards are marked for research use only
meaning you need regulatory such as fda
ua or country specific approval
to incorporate a dbs card into your test
let me answer some common questions
how does no3
903 card work actually is for
biomolecules
are that are bound to the cellulose
fiber matrix capturing the sample for a
one watt analysis upon extraction
what sample type can i apply to 903 card
paper
typically blood but any blue bodily
fluid can be applied how should i store
the unused 903 card recommendation for
the storage of 903 cars is at least at
less than 25 degree celsius and 60
degree relative humidity protected from
direct sunlight
what is the shelf life of an unused 903
card is 5 years very long shelf life if
it is in
sativa package
what panzer can be used with 903 card
any puncher
most
mostly
used any sponsor can be used
what accessories such as sponsor and mat
mats
does saitiba provide
we do not have any punchers punches we
offer but do have houses
and
desiccant we can offer to make up a kit
what happens if nitric oxides get wet
either before or after storage if the
903 card gets wet prior to sample
collection discard the unused weight
card if the product gets wet after
sample application take a punch from the
specimen
so as soon as possible and continue
processing
how do we apply the blood or
other liquid on samples
onto 903 cards products are provided
with an
protocol showing how sample should be
applied
can i reapply sample to the card after
this part has dried to get more sample
onto the 903 card not necessary because
the
amount of sample
you will have for past application you
will be good enough
can custom formats be made yes our
design team can work with you to produce
a device that will fit your needs
right
can you apply previously frozen blood to
903 cards to purify sample yes a larger
puns may be needed
though as some of these cells may have
been lysed on freezing
how many punches can i get from 1903
sample circles
depends on the punch diameter and circle
size
you can determine
can i elude dna from 903 card in
principle yes with the help of protein
sk treatment and a phenol chloroform
isomyelic alcohol
at
2524 1 ratio
extraction
uh yes this application is quite
possible
what do you mean by excessive humidity
during storage what about humidity
during shipment of spotted and or
unspotted product humidity
may compromise the sample by molecules
degradation could occur
there we recommend to use a sealed bag
containing a desiccant packet
how much blood does is card hold that's
a good one this depends on number of
circles per card each circle sample area
holds 75 to 80 microliter of sample
maximum 400 microliter for cards with
five sample areas
what certification is available
certificate of analysis is available for
nine or three paper used for each job we
normally do not provide a job-specific
certificate of analysis contrary of
origins
or origin certificates which is supplied
for
export countries as a mandatory document
are msts available no
material data safety sheet are available
[Music]
as no chemicals
are not available as no chemicals are
used for this product
what types of barcode can you print
sativa can print most barcodes that are
utilized in the industry using high
speed laser printer city back and
customize to any barcode size and is
also able to paint 2d barcodes
can you print barcodes 1903 filter paper
because of the nature of 903 filter
paper and its high absorbency sciteva
does not recommend trying to print
barcodes directly onto the 903 paper
what is your typical delivery
the complexity of the card and volume
can affect delivery however the majority
of orders can be processed and shipped
six to eight weeks after pure receipt
and customer copy approval
uh this that was my last slide let's
keep in touch thank you very much for
your time i can take your questions
dr mandel can you hear me okay yes
very good okay sounds good okay well dr
model i want to thank you for that
outstanding presentation we will now
move into the live q a portion of our
webinar now as a reminder to our
audience please submit your questions
via the q a box
okay
we have lots of questions so let's just
jump right in
our first question
how can i get more detail on the
protocols of how to use
903 cards in the many applications
you've mentioned in this presentation
all right
let me get the question uh from the
bottom
all right
just a second
sure all right um
i get uh
protocols on how to use 903 cards in
many applications you have messed in
this
uh presentation
yeah many applications for example
a nucleic acid test or antibody test or
some specific biomarkers
depending on the type of samples you're
collecting say if it is
uh blood samples
so there are three ways you can collect
the blood uh finger pricking
or belly puncture or arterial puncture
and you also can collect any kind of
biofluid like in vince liba so depending
on your sample type you your collection
protocol will be different but the
process is very simple
we have the
protocol that
how much sample can be applied per sec
depending on that
volume you can use the certain volume to
apply on the
903 card after drying for three hours at
room temperature and
you can collect the punch using a punch
puncher
and elute your samples and simple
illusion or sample preparation is
variable depending on the type of test
and
compatibility of your reagent
but the straightforward processes just
punch it out once they cut out and elude
your samples into
into a right buffer
which is suitable for your test
excellent thank you
our next question
can you speak to other sample collection
methods that you've used
all right i already discussed the
fingerprint fingerprinting sample
collection
involves
taking a very small amount of blood from
the patient usually from the end of the
finger
but arterial sampling
which is close to the
palm and this blood sample
commonly takes place within a hospital
environment arterial sampling
it is used in the identification of
metabolic respiratory and mixed
acid-based disorders where carbon
dioxide levels require understanding or
monitoring
there is an increased risk of bleeding
complications in patients with quad
glucopathy
but
benue puncture is most common way to
collect blood from adult patients from a
superficial vein in the upper limb
this uh
vein is close to the skin and doesn't
have many large nerves positioned close
by uh this reduces pain and discomfort
for the patient
there are also risks related to the
storage transportation and potential
loss of
contamination of the blood samples once
they are collected
so other than blood saliva urine or any
biofluid can be collected on sample
collection card
thank you
let's go with this one
are there use case examples in this
pandemic that you can speak of
oh definitely
recently fda
fda
approved the vibrant antibody chemi
luminescence essay for
differentiating cers coronovitis to igm
and igg antibodies
one whatman 903 card
world health organization is trying to
understand from kobit 19 pandemic
surveillance world health organization
has approved dbs system for acib
surveillance and now stepping up with
dbs sample to understand sars karna
virus 2 as well
and also well scientists have developed
a convenient look with antibody chest
for public 19 based on dried blood spot
sampling technique
it's also an automated elisa format
so these are the common examples but we
have been working with many customers
who are trying to dbs card to
incorporate
into their lateral flow system as a
sample collection device and lateral
flow test for the detection of that
sample
and finally probably
this lateral flow with the dbs card will
be approved
by fda or other eu system
yes excellent
thank you
now how long can samples be stored and
what are the best storage
conditions
um
once once after sample collection uh
depending on the analyte target it could
be antibody nucleic acid
the length of sample stability may vary
for example nucleic acid dna and rna rna
is
unstable on any sample on any
condition in any condition either liquid
or in dry
blood spot
so samples can be tested immediately or
usually can be stored in ambient
temperature even under tropical
conditions or frozen at minus 20 minus
80 degrees celsius where the level of
igc antibodies may remain stable for
several years
but the stability of dna and rna
may be variable
but it has been tested by pcr
and dna sequences several months after
sample collection even when dbs had been
held at room temperature
a recent study have shown that hiv dna
and rna can be recovered after five
years without refrigeration as well
excellent
dr mondel as swabs are in short supply
could 903 cards be used to collect
saliva mucus swabs for covid19 antigen
detection
so it has not been tested but
saliva antigen
for kobit 19 definitely it can be
collected on
a 903 card and
the customer has to
evaluate this is kind of new antigen we
don't know many characteristics customer
has to be evaluate
the stability
of the 903 card with sars coronavirus to
antigen
thank you
and with time for a few more questions
let's go with this one are there any
higher contamination risks as compared
to other sampling methods
definitely finger pricking is much safer
than any other uh methods of sample
collection
as you as we know
flavortomy the drawing of blood has been
practiced for centuries and still one of
the most common invasive procedures in
healthcare is taping the process of
libertarian such as collecting blood
shipping opening the tube
and
take the samples for testing
affects the quality of the specimen and
involvement of human hands work which
is who is caused the error
in
many ways
and it also caused the injury
for the patient for example the touch of
a finger
to verify the location of vein
before insertion of the needle
increases the chance that a specimen
will be contaminated from the hands and
these can cause false results prolong
hospitalization delay diagnosis and
cause and unnecessary use of antibiotics
also
jostling and gearing of the test tubes
in the transit can lies or break open
red blood cells causing false laboratory
tests as well
so similar
finger pricking and 903 card sample
collection even though it is safer but
definitely it requires
human involvement to clean the
fingertips and drop the blood
uh so
uh the precaution should be taken for
finger pricking as well um but this is
definitely much safer than venue
puncture
blood collection
now piggybacking off on that question
and answer can you elaborate what the
common root causes are
when sampling is done incorrectly using
these cards
right the root causes could lie
in every steps every steps that human
or the sample collecting person is
taking
people not
storing the product correctly
even after sample collection and
is not
transporting in timely way to the lab
say finger pricking at the time of
finger pricking finger must be clean
apply pressure during
say blood is not dropping out and you
need to apply a tiny pressure during
pressure if your hand
like move away from the circle then you
might
spot somewhere else and
and allow a large drop for free flowing
blood to collect
sometimes
when the circle is full you have to
remove your hand
away
so
or also
so during the touching uh when the blood
is dropping from the finger
the card uh should be in contact with
blood
and
is it is a kind of
um tricky and you have to maintain this
properly
and um
and also the drying condition if the
blood is not completely dry
so and if you put in a package
so the blood might contaminate some
other
area of the card even the envelope um
which could be risky for the handler
so the drying condition is one of the
critical
and then um
you have to fill out the name and date
of other special end date and some other
special requirement
once the card is dried it is ready to
ship and then you have to ship it
properly so there are many steps
involved
so every step could be faulty if it is
not accurately
maintained
thank you that's some great information
we have time for one more question let's
go with this one i need to track and
automate
my sampling process what options do you
have
right dry blood spot card can be
provided with scannable barcodes
which
we
which we are able to customize upon
request we are also working in
development to help create a
framed version of the 903 card which is
compatible with automation equipment
such as the hamilton eg puns
starlet
more more information is coming
please follow once available
great
thank you so much
we are out of time
but i want to tell our audience don't
worry because those questions that were
submitted and we were unable to get to
they will be answered via email and we
have your registered animation in your
email at
dr mondel thank you again so much and
thank you again to our audience for
their outstanding questions oh thank you
so much
for your cooperation and you have been
working so hard uh from the beginning of
this conference and
and uh
for this presentation and thank you my
audience for listening if you have any
question please feel free to contact me
directly we'll be happy to answer your
questions
thank you dr mandel
now i want to tell our audience as well
that today's presentation is available
for on-demand viewing for 12 months
so please remember to share this with
your colleagues who may be interested in
this topic you may also submit questions
during that on-demand period
now don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda those that
have already presented live are now
available on demand so visit that agenda
tab in the auditorium for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and dr mandel thank you again for your
time today
thank you very much
have a great day